[Music]
when we were living in carson
i got tear gas right
right
because we saw for those of you i don't
know for those of you who haven't heard
this story we're on the roof when the
protests were happening and there was a
protest happening a block from my house
well actually there was one on basically
a blockchain every time yeah
and um
i'd seen the tear gas go off and i said
to your mom i said hey
they're tear-gassing people
and she said oh my god i go i'm going
down there and she was like what i go
yeah i've never been tear gas before
and i want to know
i want to know what it feels like and
she was like that's the dumbest thing
i've ever heard but you know who would
have gone with you if he was there you
me
but that and so i went and by the way it
was
it was not great
but oh it probably hurt like a [ __ ]
they pour milk on you because that's
what kind of kills the burning you know
i didn't know i thought they were
pouring water on me
water i think makes it worse it
doesn't matter if it's
is
[Music]